[Music]
this week 150 writers and academics
signed an open letter published in
Harper's criticizing the current
canceled culture the letter was equally
praised and mocked joining me now to
react author on this book our friend
Dave Rubin all right Dave good to have
you on you know Dave this letter to me
is fascinating because you have all of
these liberals who were saying you know
we refuse any false choice between
justice and freedom we cannot have an
intolerant Society and they go on and on
in this letter about you know that
people have to accept opposing views I
just find that hysterical because
there's someone on the right we've had
hard views censured for several years
now what's your take on this yeah well
you're setting it up the right way
because look any defense I know you're
gonna agree with me on this
any defense of free speech is good
especially right now however most of the
people on there who are lefties liberals
progressives whatever you want to call
them they've been pretty much silent as
the mob has come for anyone that's right
leaning I mean we know right now what
during this show that there are people
at Media Matters who are waiting for you
judge Jeanine or me to say one word
wrong so that they can send a mob and
try to cancel advertisers they do this
with Tucker they do this with everyone
on the right and it's like where were
you guys so what's happening now is that
although it's late it's like they're
suddenly seeing their universities
crumble because Princeton and Harvard
and Yale they're all having massive
problems we all see it and we know that
all the statues are coming down as you
were talking about earlier and they're
suddenly going oh the mob is starting to
show up to my University and take down
my statues and they may show up at my
house so I better speak up but I have to
tell them it's a little too late and
I'll just say one other thing which is a
couple of the people on the list have
tried to cancel me
oh this thing was personal for me too
well I gotta tell you I read your book
don't burn this book and and I I'm sorry
I love it it's great reading it is and
but but what's thanks to me Dave is the
fact that sorry about that
what doesn't make sense to me is the
fact that they wouldn't at least attempt
to join forces with those of us on the
left because if they truly on the right
I should say because if they truly
believe that there is no choice between
justice and freedom why not align
yourself with people on the right like
with conservatives we're a stronger
United aren't we absolutely and that's
what actually my whole book and my
political evolution is about because I
was on the left and then as I saw the
left failing consistently on free speech
failing to stand up for the liberal
principles that it purported to believe
in what I suddenly found was ho look at
this there's all these people on the
right these conservatives and
libertarians who I may have some
political disagreements with that's fine
you read my book you know we disagree on
some stuff but that's okay but what do
we believe in we believe in the
Constitution we believe in free speech
we believe in free expression we believe
in capitalism we believe that
fundamentally America is a good
experiment and that's all it is it's an
ongoing experiment and yeah I think
they're they're really afraid of being
called conservative that in liberal
circles that is still the scariest thing
oh you're suddenly friends with
conservatives you must be a conservative
and and they've got to get over that
because the ivory tower is crumbling and
it's gonna crumble right on top of their
heads well the amazing part of it is
that the feelings aren't usually I mean
from what I'm but no and I'm kind of in
the middle of things here it's from the
left toward the right they don't want to
hear people on the right I've never
heard people on the right say I don't
want to hear from that person I don't
think that they should be allowed to
speak at my child's University I mean
and and we know from the time that
Donald Trump was elected that you become
you know people unfriend you they don't
want you to be a they don't want to
communicate with people I've had up my
don't taller than my children's weddings
actually they don't talk to me anymore
and it's not usually the right toward
the left I mean the intolerance is on
the left am I wrong
the the woke no the woke condition is a
mind virus what is a virus a virus is
very easy to catch and very hard to get
rid of and that's what this thing is it
all kind of sounds right everyone I
disagree with is a racist well that
sounds pretty good that's pretty lofty
once you accept those ideas you know
that if you then walk away from it you
will be called a racist so it's almost
the self hostage situation but you know
you also hit on something which is that
in the letter the implication was oh
well we're not on the right the right
still has these problems I don't think
there was one Trump supporter on there
it's like if you really want to be for a
plurality of opinions couldn't you have
found one Trump supporter or one really
staunch conservative that you you would
have believed to be signed on to that
thing so it's it's a disease of the left
right now because there's just thanks
for being with us Dave thanks so much if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlists
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell